the growing demand in the it industry
can make it confusing to pick one
programming language that is suitable
and helpful for an individual so in this
video we will walk you through the top
five programming languages for the year
2021 this list can help you plan your
career in 2021 but number five we have
java so let's look into it java was
created by james gosling in the year
1991 it is the most demanding
programming language evident by its
worldwide usage java is known for
providing the most number of jobs in the
it industry java has a large application
based in the industry with the
applications ranging from scientific
applications financial and banking
services to web and mobile development
and desktop application development the
companies using java as their
programming language are ibm hcl infosys
among many others java developers with a
few years of experience can earn nearly
117 000 pa and in india they can earn
around 10 lakh rupees pa next up we have
the r programming language r was
conceived by robert gentleman and ross
ihaka in 1992. r is a comprehensive and
statistical analysis language and it
encourages developers to implement new
ideas r works best on linux gnu and
microsoft windows the application of rs
in the field of data science statistical
computing and machine learning although
r is difficult to learn it is considered
as the future programming language the
companies using rs their programming
language are capgemini cognizant
accenture among many others our
developers with a few years of
experience can easily earn nearly 150
000 pa and in india they can earn around
9 lakh rupees pa moving on to number
three we have kotlin kotlin is a general
purpose programming language originally
developed by jetbrains it is
interoperable with java and also
supports functional programming
languages kotlin is used extensively for
android development web development
desktop application development and
server side development kotlin was built
to be better than java and people who
use this language believe it most of the
google applications are based on kotlin
the companies using kotlin as their
programming language are coursera
pinterest postmates among many others
according to glassdoor kotlin developers
with a few years of experience can earn
nearly 140 000 pa and in india they can
earn 8 lakh rupees pa next we have php
php programming language was initially
created for the purpose of maintaining a
personal website but since then it has
taken over 24 of websites globally php
language is generally used to create
static and dynamic websites and some
popular web frameworks like laravel are
built upon php
php introduces dynamic changes to a
website and makes web applications more
interactive the companies using php as
their programming language are facebook
yahoo mailchimp among many others
according to glassdoor php developers
can earn nearly 101 000 pa and in india
they can earn around 7 lakh rupees pa on
average at first position we have python
programming language python is the
fastest growing and one of the most
popular programming languages with
reliable and well-built frameworks it is
open source and easy to learn python is
used in many areas in the industry
django framework which is based on
python is popularly used in web
development furthermore python has
become the preferred programming
language for machine learning and
artificial intelligence few of the big
companies that use python for
development are instagram spotify amazon
and facebook python developers can earn
nearly 107 000 pa and in india they can
earn around 8 lakh rupees pa on that
note why don't you check out the simply
learns postgraduate program in ai and
machine learning created in partnership
with purdue university and in
collaboration with ibm we'll cover a
number of topics and concepts like
statistics python machine learning deep
learning networks nlp reinforcement
learning and much more to help you grow
in your career and there you go those
are the top programming languages in
2021 with that we've reached the end of
this video do you agree with our top 10
list is there any other programming
language that is worth learning in 2021
let us know in the comments thank you
for watching this video and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here